The reason doesn't matter.
Nor that this man is my enemy.
Nor that someone put me to sleep.
What matters...
is that for hours,
this man, on the brink of death...
although I am his enemy...
protected me!
What remains is the fact
that I was protected by this man!
I will not let him die!
The first floor of the Shin Shin Kai HQ...
has a treatment room staffed
with a doctor!
Only the back?
Apologies! My name is Retsu.
You can contact me
at the Shin Shin Kai Karate Dojo!
Karate?
Kung Fu?
Our destination is just past this...
One kilometer to the bridge.
I have no other choice.
Distance, 10 meters.
About 700 to 800 steps.
It won't be a problem for about 15 meters!
He's crossing... the river...
With two of us...
we can't help but sink.
No one's going to believe this.
Even if I tell someone.
I apologize for the disturbance!